it's great to welcome to the program
today Natalie Wynne who is a video
essayist and progressive commentator
with half a million subscribers to her
YouTube channel contra points which I
know many people in my audience Natalie
are familiar with you've been one of the
most requested guests on the show so I'm
glad glad we were able to make it happen
oh I'm glad I can be here hi everyone so
to start with let's assume someone's not
familiar with you your videos have a
very particular style your background is
in academia Graduate academia in
philosophy so you bring a sort of
different perspective than than maybe
many other commentators what's kind of
your general approach what are you
trying to do with your video essays well
I'd say they're kind of like political
video essays or sometimes even more like
dramatic pieces that basically try to
make the most difficult political
controversies of our day and to us like
sort of entertaining question basically
so I guess I would I would say that as
persuasion what I'm trying to do is kind
of reach like basically a mainstream
youtube audience people who like jokes
and memes and want to be entertained but
instead of doing the usual thing that
you do when you want to entertain people
with politics which is you know make
feminists cringe compilation part 57
what I do is try to create a more like
thoughtful video essay sort of in the
vein of like the kind of genre of like
very well-written in research like film
review that goes on on YouTube except
about politics and to keep that
entertaining and engaging and funny and
not taking myself too seriously yeah
yeah so we'll get into some of the
specific topics you've covered in
fascism and authoritarianism is of
interest to me in to my audience so
we'll get to that but one of the you
mentioned persuasion one of the things I
think you and I agree on that maybe is
different than a part of what the
considers itself to be the left is the
idea that just because you have the
right argument from a logical
perspective doesn't mean that you're
going to succeed in the area of
persuasion I
actually also gone even further to say
that I think sometimes you shouldn't
even bother with persuasion on certain
topics and with certain people but we
can we can maybe get to that can you
give us some examples of where the left
you feel is right logically but is
unable to persuade well I think that
it's a pretty common problem I mean I
think that one thing thought I come on
so that sort of leftist commentary from
like it was called again in SJW kind of
angle that is I was doing a lot of stuff
on gender and race and I think that you
know for a lot of people that entire
type was called the what's derided as
identity politics always comes across as
accusatory right like especially to you
know this seems to be this like
defensive reaction that gets provoked
like in white men in particular because
the discourse around those topics tends
to be on the left it's very like sort of
like you're so privileged and you did
all these horrible things to us and
people no one wants to hear that so you
know even if it's true you know if
people feel that their group is being
attacked or they're being attacked for
the group that they belong to they
basically shut down and don't listen now
there are some people who will act as if
that's what you're saying even if you're
saying nothing even close to that so
it's a little complicated but I do think
that what I'm making about kind of
argument I take care to do everything I
can to sort of minimize that reaction of
defensiveness to always not make people
feel personally attacked but like I'm
trying to help them see something in a
new way rather than like coming at them
like guns blazing pointing a finger and
blaming yeah the identity politics issue
is interesting because I don't know if
you saw a couple of months ago there's
this black tea party guy David Webb who
has a Sirius XM radio show and he was
interviewing some legal analysts and it
was a phone interview so the legal
analyst couldn't see him and when the
topic of white privilege came up the
legal analyst said David Webb has his
show at least in part because of white
privilege which of course was
faceplant since he's black and the
entire thing devolved into just a
disaster
and my my analogy out of it was we if we
want to make coherent and persuasive
arguments about an issue like white
privilege it actually shouldn't matter
what the identity of the person making
the argument or receiving the argument
is because you end up in exactly these
types of situations where you now are
starting to argue about whether a
particular person is the beneficiary or
not of white privilege if you have your
black of course it's hard to make that
case but that we should instead focus on
the societal impact and the underlying
values and priorities do you think that
that is a fair interpretation of where
identity based arguments can work and
can fail or is there a sort of different
way you would synthesize it I would say
that's definitely one of the things like
I guess it you know even when I know and
I feel that an the audience I'm talking
to if I feel that some of their
sensitivities are unfair or unreasonable
I will sometimes try to be sort of cater
to them anyway like I spend a lot of
time talking about transgender issues
and a lot of people just the word
transphobia just makes them like shut
down I don't know why exactly but I just
empirically have noticed that it does
and so I'll try to find a way around
saying the word transphobia since it
seems to be just a trigger word for
closed minds closing their doors
what's it so what other terms do you use
I'm curious I will say like ignorant
about trans people for example or
disgust towards trans people or you know
things like that
yeah I've experienced that with the
movement that is skeptical about
vaccines and I'm choosing my words
carefully because I realized that
there's a sort of similar kind of
triggering effect shutdown effect when
you use the term anti-vaxxer even if for
all practical purposes it's a relevant
and accurate term there there seems to
be something similar there although I
guess from a practical practical
perspective
curious does avoiding the term
transphobia and using the other terms
actually allow you to have more
productive conversations do you think or
be more persuasive I think at the right
moment it can like I think some people
you know it doesn't matter but I think
what words like anti-vaxxer or
transphobia do is that they're a little
bit jargony so they're sort of
shibboleths they signal that you are in
a member of a certain party right like
it's a kind of person with a kind of
education that says the word transphobia
it's a kind of person whose mind is made
up that says the word anti-vaxxer and so
when you use the last specialty word
you're kind of it's like centrist virtue
signaling or something right like you're
say you're signaling to the audience
that like oh I am an independent three
free thinker I'm putting things in my
own words because these are just my
ideas that I came up with myself you
know you're entering with an open mind
it's sort of can can signal which can be
useful in having some of these
conversations okay let's let's talk a
little bit if we apply that to your
videos that you've done on fascism on
the alt right I mean I think it might be
useful as we get into this topic first
and foremost when when we talk about
fascism what's the sort of useful
working definition that will serve us in
exploring this issue in more detail well
I guess I avoid the defining or a word
like fascism too directly but I think a
working definition would be like
politics that's kind of primarily
motivated by a kind of national or ethno
in-group out-group sentiment so if the
primary motivation for your politics is
sort of preserving the boundaries of an
ethnic group of a nation a tional group
that to me is fascist politics I guess
there's other attributes too like it
pretty much always goes along with like
very reactionary views about women and
about sort of social issues it pretty
much always goes along with some degree
of like militancy or you know tendency
towards violence at ten
to go along with a kind of
authoritarianism or sort of worship of a
dictator or leader but to me the core
issue is the like this this idea of
treating a society almost like God
organism like treating it like you know
this sort of being prone to infection
fiction so we understood as outsiders in
thinking about that I mean I've I've
interviewed a lot of former and and
active I guess I would say white
nationalists extremists neo-nazis and in
talking to the formers typically when I
asked them about how they were pulled in
to the ideology and the movements of
white nationalism or neo Nazism or
whatever it's almost exclusively an
answer about family situation what their
life was like growing up the particulars
of seeing a group that that that was
appealing to them for the community and
the belief sort of came with it and they
accepted them with different degrees of
actual belief so if we step back a
little bit from the individual stories
that might be out there about how people
get pulled into these ideologies at a
more like societal level what do you
believe is appealing about the sort of
fascism maybe light fascism in the sense
of authoritarianism nationalism etc what
is attractive about that to people from
a philosophical perspective well I think
fascism provides people with a strong
sense of identity and that sort of goes
along with what you're saying about the
fact that this type of politics tends to
be attractive to people who are sort of
lost and not they're sort of trying to
find themselves they want acceptance
they want to feel like they're part of a
group they want to feel like they're
part of a collective that's working
towards something they want to feel like
they know who they are and can make
sense of their own individual identity
and where they fit into society and I
think that against a background of the
kind of like really like sort of
meaningless capitalism that we have
about when I say meaningless capitals I
mean that like the sort of pre-made of
you system that our society hands to
people is very sort of materialistic
it's very sort of almost like
frivolously like it's consumerist and so
on and that leaves people you know so
some people find like a consumer
identity as like a gamer or something
but for most a lot of people that's like
not enough especially if they're in
they're in a rough employment situation
or they're just impoverished they're
they're you know they have family
problems like you say like they're not
succeeding by them bag of the metrics of
our society right they're not so they
want to know like Who am I what what am
i what is my value like where do I fit
in in this world and fascism has easy
answers to all those questions it says
you are the sort of descendant of this
like noble European heritage and you are
the descendant of Voltaire and of
Christopher Columbus and all this great
stuff though the European West has
accomplished and that offers people I
think a sense of pride a sense of
identity a sense of worth a sense of
purpose a sense of belonging and all
that stuff is very very attractive it's
hard to contend with a movement that's
offering people all that and though I
can't help but think that for some
people similar sort of circumstances of
feeling lost and most everything else
you're describing could lead someone and
does to say I think that for example
socialism is the right path forward I
think that so is there anything that we
can identify that might push someone
more towards one side or the other be it
psychologically be it may be by virtue
of what country you're in
well I think that one of the reasons
when one of the ways fascism works is it
preys on resentments and sort of
ignorance and insecurities that are
already there so I mean to me the
alt-right was like fascinating in terms
of how sort of psychologically open it
was like how like almost embarrassingly
honest like I remember when they were
using the word [ __ ] all the time yeah
that first started in like 20
fifteen 2016 like it almost like it sort
of made me gasp that we were being like
so like sigh sexually transparent about
the like deep motivations for this like
there's this anxiety about masculinity
and about women and about white women in
particular and this anxiety about you
know sort of the replacement of white
men by immigrant men and like it's I
think that those kinds of things are
sort of there in the background and did
you know I think men tend to be very
susceptible to fascism because it offers
a kind of masculinist gender politics
that is sort of attractive to men who
feel that that the society that we're in
is actually kind of like emasculating
and I think that that is sort of a
common feeling that a lot of internet
subgroups have like what we call the
manosphere in cells you know sort of the
kind of college-aged boys who get really
into jordan Peterson for example there's
a deep insecurity about masculinity
there and in a sort of sexual insecurity
and fascism actually offers a really
kind of attractive package to that set
of worries that's a perfect spot
actually which will lead us into part
two of the interview which will start to
connect the Donald Trump administration
and some of the movements that are
surrounding him so let's pause our
conversation there with Natalie wind
video essayist progressive commentator
you may know her from the YouTube
channel contra points now with half a
million subscribers and we will continue
our conversation there we're continuing
our conversation today with Natalie win
a video essayist and progressive
commentator with half a million
subscribers to her YouTube channel
contra points we're going to continue
our conversation about fascism and
authoritarianism and I want to now start
to tie in some of your analysis about
not only the alt-right it now in 2018
2019 and in sort of recent electoral
politics but also the connection to
donald trump's authoritarian tendencies
do you think or let me frame it in this
way when I interviewed white nationalist
Richard Spencer and I said to him
what exactly is that that you expect
from Trump do you actually expect him to
say down with the Jews or get white
people out or whatever and Richard
Spencer I think was pretty genuine in
that he said no we don't have any
expectations of that it's basically that
we recognize that more than any other
recent president Trump seems indifferent
to or at least okay
allowing an atmosphere where white
nationalism and the resurgence of
neo-nazism
sort of has a better shot than it's had
is that as far as you would go in
thinking about the connection of the
Trump administration to these movements
or would you actually take it further
than that um I would go further I first
of all I think that he's about that
that's correct like I think that a lot
of the kind of the reason that so many
people who are white nationalists love
Donald Trump is that Donald Trump is
very cautious never to sort of intrude
too much on their space to never really
condemn directly any of the things they
believe and that leaves room for them
always to think that he might secretly
be on their side but more than that I
mean I think like I've seen white
nationalists called Trump like the
strongest like symbol of white identity
we have and I think that a lot of that
has to do with like the central
marketing basically of his campaign this
would build the wall thing well the wall
is like almost a just like a childishly
laughably primitive symbol of like
wanting to protect an in-group from an
out group and I don't think anyone who
voted for Trump really cares that much
about the physical wall I think what
they care about is the sentiment behind
the slogan build the wall and means shut
outsiders away it means Keep America
American and we know what that means
so I think that it's more than just his
silence it's more than just saying that
there are good people on both sides in
Charlottesville you know it's also the
fact that his messaging is kind of the
diet version of Richard Spencer's
messaging so you mentioned a couple of
the data points there's you know
Mexicans are rapists and criminals
although some I'm sure there are good
people there
total and complete shutdown of as I
think he pronounced that Muslims coming
to the United States what what other
data points do you look at that are
either coded or moreover language that
is is signaling to these extremist
groups well I mean attacking an Tifa is
a pretty obvious one I think that's just
his whole campaigning on like America
first make America great again which is
like I mean who wants to make America
who is for what group of people was
America better in the past like white
people everyone knows that I think that
all these things kind of have are all
each of his major talking points is in
some way laced with an element that is
going to be sort of attractive to people
who like why nationalism he did a talk
and he did a speech in Poland that I
think was this is like the first his
must have been twenty they the first
year of his presidency and he talks I
think this was Steven Miller I think it
was a speech but it was on you know he's
talking about defacing literally just
talking about defending the West from
like you know the barbarians like it's
like it's it's not even dog was those
anymore it's like literally what the
white nationalists will say are any of
these so-called threats that the current
sort of all trite white nationalist Venn
diagram group however however it
overlaps on any particular day are any
of the threats they claim to be facing
even remotely defensible that of you
know what I mean white genocide is just
absolutely outrageous but the idea of
possible loss of some kind of status for
so-called
European Americans the invasion of
immigration as they like to describe I
mean is there anything that even has
like a grain of empirical defense
ability well I do think that for like
again the kind of college-age white boy
demographic there is the sense that you
know that group of people just used to
be able to assume themselves as the
default like they assumed they were
going to get
jobs cuz society was gonna provide them
jobs that's how I they were raised they
raised to expect that they were just
used to being represented as the default
in media they were used to Star Wars
movies where all the main characters are
white men are designed to be perceived
by white man you know and then suddenly
there's this huge cultural shift
suddenly women and people of color and
gender and sexual minorities are making
demands and asserting themselves in
appearing in media and getting jobs and
so there's this loss of the default
status which like I mean in some ways it
must hurt a little bit like I think that
I I can understand why it feels like
they're losing something like I think
they are losing something I mean I think
they it's something that they didn't
deserve in the first place it needs to
go and I think they need to recognize
that but I still got why it feels like a
loss yes so in other words they may be
claiming that a situation that was a
level playing field is becoming one in
which they are disadvantaged when if
there is a change in status what what
accurately seems to describe it would be
that what was previously a privileged
status may end up with a more level
playing field
well there's yeah a slogan I guess that
describes that I can't remember the
exact wording but basically the effect
is that to the privileged person
equality feels like you crush him I
think I've seen that and I think that
that much more succinctly than I was
able to say it sort of sums it up what
when it comes to individual extremists
white nationalists whoever I'm curious
what your senses of the platforming or
interviewing of some of those
individuals so to kind of set it up for
you my audience is very much aware of
this over the last many years on my
program I have selectively interviewed
extremists of different kinds and
usually I apply like a two or three part
kind of test to whether it's a good idea
number one is are they and their ideas
prominent enough that there would be
some value in refuting and exposing them
that would be number one number two do I
feel as though I am either prepared
enough or could be prepared enough to
responsibly platform them such that it
doesn't become
an opportunity for them to actually
propagandize and if the answer to both
of those questions is yes I've made the
decision in the past to interview people
like Richard Spencer or the Westboro
Baptist Church when they were relevant
or whoever else given all of that that
I've just said what's your kind of
general philosophy on the providing of a
platform even if it is one that is not
an an unfettered platform to
propagandize to extremists well I think
I basically agree with what you're
describing as the sort of like tests
that you need to go through just decide
if it's a good idea even very very
critical in the past of people who have
interviewed Richard Spencer for example
and then just kind of sat there nodding
along as he spouts incredibly toxic
white nationalist propaganda so I think
in part has to do with the like
personality of the interviewer and
whether or not you feel that sort of
holding your own and keeping this person
accountable in front of an audience is
something that that you can do
effectively so I think that way I agree
with you what you're saying like there's
absolutely no point and profiling a
dangerous crockpot with no following
because you're just gonna give them
attention and then if you're going to
profile a high profile person with
extremely toxic and dangerous ideas then
you have to be prepared to challenge
them and to really you know to really
ask the very very difficult questions
that they're not you know that are going
to sort of expose the reality of what
the person is saying so this is not
something I do myself in part because I
my temperament is not aggressive enough
to do it and in part because I am a
trans woman and my comrades on the Left
do not tolerate that from me
oh well that okay so I want to hear more
so you're saying that because of your
identity as a trans woman you feel that
other leftists wouldn't tolerate you
interviewing extremists at all or in the
way that your personality would lend
itself to those interviews well I think
it's just not the role for me and I
think that it's it's sort of complicated
the reasons why I mean one
is has to do with the fact that in order
to do it properly you have to be a
little bit combative to be combative is
a masculine posture and if a trans woman
adopts a masculine posture she always
loses
that's very interesting and have you so
I'm curious whether is this something
people have said to you and you've made
the conscious decision not to do those
types of interviews or is this sort of
something that you've surmised from your
observations as to how people react to
your channel well this was something
that I kind of went through you know a
year and a half ago where basically it
was something that that was surmised by
based on people's reactions like I had
done sort of I had you know I didn't
really interview people that was never
what I did online but I would even go on
other I would go on to right-wing
platforms and try to be a person who
challenged it now maybe some of the
objection to me was that people felt I
wasn't strong enough to Bator that I
wasn't able to really do that
responsibly but it always was a little
weird to me that I was accused of
platforming people whose platforms I was
appearing on yeah I saw I think I saw a
conversation you had with this gentleman
named Carl Benjamin who might be better
known to the audio as a sargon of akkad
and yeah I mean I think you know the
appearing on other programs also is
there's always a question mark around
the kind of framing in context in which
the conversation will be happening and
whether there's kind of a net net gain
to be had and I think the calculation is
different for everybody in those cases
oh definitely I mean I I don't think
that I said it's it's a it's complicated
it's not just that I was felt I was
chuffed shut down by other people I do
feel obviously a little bit hurt about
that but I was not the greatest debater
myself so but you know nor was I given
the space to develop the skill so I'm
curious I mean aside from individual
decisions around platforming of oneself
elsewhere or of others on one's platform
what in your mind are the best sort of
insulators that allow people to resist
the appeal of some of these fascist
authoritarian alt-right nationalist type
ideas I mean is it just as simple as
we've got to start teaching
thinking in middle school or is there
really more to it well I think it's more
than just critical thinking because
critical thinking well that involves a
lot of different stuff I mean sometimes
critical thinking is just like how to
analyze grass how to analyze data sure I
think that is important I think that a
lot of times these arguments are so
heavily based on sort of an emotional
hook that it's really like a
statistician would fall for them because
that's it's not about numbers it's about
feelings and to me I think that one of
the one of the things that's a
protective shield is having some kind of
personal connection to people who are
likely to be deeply hurt by that
politics so I think that there's a kind
of you know social isolation like I
think that you know as a trans person
this is something I experienced that on
YouTube where you know the reason one of
the reasons why the right wing has taken
to using trans people as this punching
bag is that most people don't know
transfer sense so people are sort of
ignorant trans people are confusing no
one gets it and so we're sort of easy to
hate on because like no one's gonna come
to our defense because they don't know
enough to come to our defense and I
think that one of the things that I try
to accomplish just by being a somewhat
high profile person on the Internet is
to just be like hi like I'm here I'm
human I'm relatable like you don't want
to do things that are we gonna be hurt
me and politics you know I mean I agree
but it's also one of the most depressing
realities and when I see you know you
hear about Republican senator rethinks
view on gay marriage because their son
has come out as gay okay great like yeah
count someone who now has taken the
correct position but it's very
depressing that only when it affects
them in such an acute way do they
actually rethink how this is affecting
people it's depressing how little
imagination people have to like like to
how to be a career homophobe and
politician have you never once thought
what if my son was gay like how can you
have not thought that yeah and and of
course the other the other side of that
is if views that you thought were so
logical and correct and deeply-held are
so quickly changed as soon as you have a
personal personal connection to the
issue maybe that suggests some of your
other views aren't as rock-solid as you
might imagine yes write your reviews
about race your views about gender your
fate you know it's some I guess I guess
misogyny is kind of the one outlier here
because men who know women seem to have
no difficulty hating them yeah that one
is different that would that is an
interesting one yeah it's different yeah
we have been speaking with Natalie Wynne
who is the video essayist and
progressive commentator don't miss her
YouTube channel contra points with half
a million subscribers Natalie I really
appreciate your time and you talking to
me today
of course thanks so much for having me
on